Welcome everybody to the h,
three podcast,
soundboard experience.
Little late on the uptake there guys,
but better,
you know,
pretty close.
Thank you to today's sponsors,
postmates dollar shave club,
that really.
And a forehand coming up and the month
ahead.
We've got Jack Septic eye,
the sweetest man on youtube coming up
next week.
Bert Kreischer.
We've been waiting and waiting to get
burke crusher in here.
Super Funny Comedian.
Love Him.
Great.
He was actually one of our first
earliest guests we've had on here.
It was such a funny episode last into
oblivion.
And uh,
he just,
he deserves better than that.
You know,
I felt bad about that,
but we're going to do good the second.
This one's not going to be as good as
that one.
Nothing will ever top that tenacious d
song,
the greatest song in the world.
You know that song.
It's like that.
Nothing will ever be as great as the
greatest thing in the world,
but this is attributed to it.
And then after that we've got tim.
Hi Decker.
Aye.
That's exciting.
And then after that,
yet again,
later in the month,
Adam Carolla all sealed in great,
wonderful guests.
Huge month ahead.
Very excited.
Thank you.
And before we get into it,
you guys have seen us rocking.
Grateful dead merchant.
I love grateful dead.
I love their merchant as much as I love
their music.
Well guess what?
We got her own grateful dead inspired
merge.
Say whoa.
You can't really feel that she gets
naked air for a sec.
Look at this.
Oh my God.
So sick introductory productions.
You've got shredder.
You got both of us.
I mean it's sick.
Tie Dye,
soda represent.com/h
the extra take extra thick hat.
Where are you at?
Represent the shirt is sick.
I haven't been aware.
This shirt.
Straight up.
Shane Dawson style.
I'm going to wear this everywhere
because I love it that much.
Um,
that's about it.
I've got a question.
So what did you say the link though?
Because it's represent dotcom slash h
three h three.
You got it on the screen.
This is what all the sponsors make you.
Do they go r,
r e p r e s e n t.com?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know how to spell represent that
gob slash street twice.
Whatever,
whatever.
Just look what's on the screen.
I don't know what I'm doing.
Um,
let me ask you this.
You're right.
When you give somebody food,
you feed them,
right?
But when you give somebody water,
what is that verb called?
You were water.
Then there.
There's no word for that.
Is there?
What is the word for when you give
somebody water?
When you give them a drink.
Not Feed.
Could you say feed them water?
You drink them.
There's no word.
How is there no word for that?
Clench your watch.
Oh,
I quenched him.
No,
your water flowers,
right?
Yeah,
but you don't want.
That doesn't mean this like I.
This has been really troubling me this
week.
People say Ethan,
serious troubles.
People say,
Ethan,
you haven't been posting video
disappeared.
What?
Have you been traveling?
Yeah,
I hadn't been able to get over the fact
this whole week that there's no word for
the word to drink to give somebody water
and the English language we have,
we're celebrated for having $100
thousand in the world going by far the
most words of any language that ever
existed.
English language,
no word for giving water and anybody in
the chat got to answer.
There's no chat.
That's true.
I don't think there's A.
I don't think that exists to drink,
so that's been really keeping me up at
night.
Frankly speaking.
Maybe in the comments you guys will
figure it out,
but guys,
I googled it and for a baby you suckle
them well.
Yeah,
that sounds right.
Yeah.
My friend was thirsty so I suckled him
some of my water.
I think that that sounds like.
I was like,
hey buddy,
here you think is suckling the
microphone for audio.
You got to work for third.
I'm thirsty.
So what happens with somebody is thirsty
and you gave them something.
There's no word,
there's no freaking word.
How is there no word for that?
You does that mind bending like,
and I've gone my whole life to until
this week without realizing that that's
what's weird to this person is saying I
would go with hydrate,
get real.
You know what?
How can I have some water?
Yeah.
Here the hydrate,
hydrate,
you know,
that's not right.
Feed.
I fed him.
There's no freaking word
for some reason you would say water.
The horse water.
The horse.
Oh,
water.
The flour.
But it's not for people.
You could water a horse proudly.
You could say feeding and watering the
horses so you could water the.
I mean,
it's a little confusing to be honest.
Half of me expects that somebody is just
going to say it.
And I'm like,
oh,
of course.
Yeah.
Uh,
you tinkle tinkle like,
oh,
obviously no,
there's no freaking word.
So I'm,
I'm looking to this ongoing debate about
your wish.
There was a chat right now.
Yeah,
it'd be nice.
Can we invent a word?
Like what works with fed feed and drank?
I drank them some water.
That sounds weird.
She made a little [inaudible].
So anyway,
let's get on with it.
All right.
I got a good one actually.
I've never heard of this word before.
Apparently this is a thing to slake
someone.
Okay.
Like a lake,
but with dance.
Hey Dan,
get the frick out of town.
Nobody it.
Nobody on this show,
right?
This is a family show,
Dan.
I'm like,
as a new one to me,
I don't know guys.
We've got a lot to get to today.
All my God,
we've got Alex Jones banned from every
social media.
I got some thoughts about that.
I think you guys might enjoy listening
to or not.
It was one of the things when you
express your opinion about something
like that,
it's like,
I liked you.
I followed you for years up until this
very moment when our opinions diverse on
this one thing and now I'm going to
stalk you and threaten your family.
Okay.
It's just an opinion,
folks.
You might disagree with it,
but it's just my opinion.
It's not a right opinion,
so that's coming up.
Very excited about that.
Ajit pies.
Back in the news.
I'm excited to talk about the fact that
me and Isla trying to have kids and I
went to a fertility clinic and squirted
in a cup to analyze my semen and it was
a fricking weird and wild experience
that I can't wait.
I took the pictures.
I want to tell you that it was something
else,
man,
and a lot of other really exciting
headlines.
I you guys are gonna love there was
apparently in Louisiana.
We'll save it.
I'll save it.
My dudes.
I'm going to save it all,
but before we get into all of that,
it's the goal for the day.
What do we got?
Let's break the ice.
Does the good for the day work?
Yo.
Let's break the ice.
Not Saying,
hey,
Pierce Morgan tries to sound smart.
Okay.
On Good Morning Britain.
I haven't seen this one.
Her forehead's really glowing on her
forehead.
Very Cup.
That is for glow.
Like you should think.
She's trying to be reflective here and
it's like,
whoa.
But that's not a good look.
It just looks like she got a greasy ass
for it.
I mean,
I'm not trying to make fun,
I shouldn't make fun of her.
I'm just saying.
I'm just saying it could be that she was
going for that.
There is makeup for that.
I,
I'm just saying if you put her at the
top of a light tower and spun her ass
around,
you could probably navigate some ships,
don't you?
No,
no,
no.
It's really not that bad.
So anyway.
Um,
so even a brief history of time,
definitely just avoid those types yet to
treat a girl.
Ryan,
read the brief history of time by
Professor Stephen.
A brief history of time is that history
is the study into black holes.
Pythagoras theorem to the nearest five
decimal places.
Do you have a favorite color?
This is like I'm,
I'm embodied by so much cringe that he's
trying to like make her look stupid.
Ask Good in understanding that if you
ever read a brief history of time by
Professor Stephen Hawking,
I'm like trying to see like,
oh,
you're dumb.
I don't think this girl ever tried to
sound smart.
I don't think she ever presumed to be
smart.
And then so the genius Piers Morgan
measure being a grown man to try to
humiliate some girl who's obviously not
the brightest,
but she's not out here being like trying
to get a Phd dissertation,
you know,
she's dumb and she knows it.
He's like,
have you ever read this book by
Professor Stephen Hawking,
who has except fucking nerds?
But like,
um,
she's not up there trying to be smart
dude,
what are you trying to disprove?
She knows she's dumb.
She's like,
no,
I'm not into that stuff.
I'm an idiot.
You know that like,
what's your point?
And then the best part is this,
he exposes himself to be the real turd
sandwich.
Let's see it.
Three point one,
four,
seven.
There's certainly the first four digits.
Fucking idiot.
Here's the best part.
First of all,
he named the digits for something
entirely else.
It's pie and he gets it wrong.
Nice.
I don't know that.
That's just what they said.
You knew that,
didn't you?
Haley was wrong.
Maybe I read that,
but like a normal person when wouldn't
know that pierce yet.
Bip.
Yeah.
You just showed yourself.
I don't even
know how you get back on the TV after
that humiliation,
but.
So that's a bit of a goof of the day.
What were you saying,
Dan?
Ian has an answer about the drink
situation.
No,
I just typed that when you said only
nerds have read that book.
Ian's like,
I'm kidding.
I thought about.
I've thought about picking up booklet.
I'm sorry again.
And it's like fuck.
And do you know the pie to the fifth
digit?
Uh,
no.
Fucking idiot.
What a moron.
You idiot.
What else?
We have one other good for the day.
Yoko Ono,
the legendary.
A lover soulmate of the great John
Lennon artists.
Artists.
Yeah,
I don't,
I don't mean to discount her.
She's done so much more than just be the
soul mate of John,
of John Lennon.
So she's come out with a new album and
she released a new single that I thought
was a provocative,
emotional,
um,
incredible moving things moving.
It's called war zone.
Excuse me guys.
So she's continuing her legacy,
just trying to kick it and if you're
trying to turn up the party or maybe put
yourself to bed with some relaxing
towns,
either recommend Yoko Ono.
Warzone war zone is available for
preorder now at Yoko Ono,
warzone.com.
One word
and the vocals words and music by Yoko
Ono produced by Yoko Ono.
And um,
it really does it all she is,
is she's got it all.
Drawing from the new album war zone
preorder everywhere.
Oh,
come on now.
Preach it girl.
Out The war zone out there.
There's sometimes
bad singers that are like,
Bob Dylan's a bad singer.
So anyone can see they've made a ball.
No,
I don't think Bob Dylan's a bad singer,
but it's like they take it too far.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Hey,
I'm feeling it.
So you can expect it
to be seeing this in the club on the
radio.
How is this not on youtube trending?
It will be after this.
After this h three bumps.
Just needed a little exposure.
Anyway,
guys,
as I said,
preorders are available now while
supplies last.
Is it bad to make fun of somebody for
their artist?
I'm not making fun.
I'm indoors.
I'm an independent artist.
I'm promoting independent artist doing
that.
Or is that.
We're interested in joining some art and
now my dude's onto the main story at
Alex Jones.
You all know him.
The notorious conspiracy theorist,
right wing.
I want to say a lot of people consider
them right,
right wing.
I don't consider them right when I
consider him an alien.
I feel like I'm making them affiliated
with a political party is like trying to
pin down like um,
what country you exist to on Mars.
I don't know if that made sense.
I feel like even Martha's to or is to.
Is to,
to grounded of it.
Yeah.
Now the time.
Well anyway,
we'll get into that,
but essentially you guys know Alex
Jones,
Info wars.
He was recently banned by Youtube,
apple,
spotify,
and facebook banned all the channels
removed.
He has been making videos since about
early 2001 now.
Today.
He's mostly known for conspiracy
theories and he's very right leaning and
that he has a lot of conspiracy theories
and a lot of targeted opinions about
like Hillary Clinton and Obama and what
do you call the pizza gate stuff he was
deep into.
I find it kind of interesting if you go
back into 2001 just to lay the
groundwork on who this guy is.
Back in 2001.
I have this clip from waking life.
He wasn't really a politically
affiliated guy.
I just found this interesting.
He was very much
antigovernment,
anti-party propaganda,
rolling across the picket line,
lay down,
lay down Gi.
We saw it all about the government
system of control.
Very much
specifically says in this clip like that
he's not a member of any party.
So somehow his,
his,
you know,
his style has changed since then
regardless.
Um,
so this is what happened.
This is from verge,
which is confirmed by Youtube.
They confirmed this,
this information here,
conspiracy theorist Alex Jones,
Youtube Channel received a strike on
Tuesday for violating the site's
community guidelines.
The verge has learned youtube for videos
from Jonestown,
which has two point 4 million
subscribers that contain instances of
hate speech,
child endangerment sources,
mailer with the matters set.
Youtube channels are deleted if they get
three strikes in a three month period to
videos contained hate speech against
Muslims,
a third contain hate speech against
transgender people.
Sources said a fourth show to child who
was pushed to the ground by an adult man
under the headline.
How to prevent liberalism.
All for the videos.
Yeah,
I,
I'll for the videos are currently posted
on info wars.
Now,
obviously I can't speak about those
specific for videos because it's so hard
to find.
I mean his shit's been scorched earth
from Youtube and shit.
So it's really hard to find the clips
and question.
So I'm just,
you know,
reading the description.
Uh,
but this one I do have the offending
video.
Oh,
those videos don't include a new one,
which was one of his new greatest hits
of him making a threatening rant about
Robert Mueller,
Mueller,
or molar.
You alert.
I always taught it's smaller,
but he didn't get it.
He says,
so I'm confused.
Were stirred a controversy earlier this
week after it was posted on facebook
that it does not appear to have been
uploaded to youtube.
Post on Info wars to the view had been
posted in a news documentary,
scientific,
artistic contact,
by the way there.
Anyway,
the first reach out to info wars,
Yada Yada,
Yada.
Jones channel previously received
strikes from youtube in February after
promoted the false theory that survivors
of the Parkland shooting were actually
trained crisis actors that violated
youtube policy against harassment and
bullying,
but strikes expired three months after
they are issued.
Dot Jones channel currently had just one
strike against him.
Now.
I actually was able to find the clip of
him talking about Robert Muller.
And,
um,
I thought,
well,
let's,
let's see what kind of stuff this guy is
saying you the question right now,
the real debate is like,
is this a,
it's being framed by the people who
support Alex Jones as a political
silencing that he's being shut down
because all these big tech companies
are,
are super liberal leaning and it's a,
it's a,
it's a political shut down,
right?
It's censorship,
So I'm like,
all right,
well like some of the videos they
described could easily be like
completely open to debate.
Look,
they're like pushing the children to the
ground.
So like,
I don't know,
I'd have to see that.
Who knows?
But here I have this one of molar,
so let's watch this.
Let me pop this baby open.
Now,
this just happened very recently.
Muir,
everyone's so scared of Mueller.
So I'm saying in front of people what
she did.
So here we go.
This is what he's saying about one
sheets.
Mueller molar is like a lifelong
Republican,
solid.
I mean,
he's one of the most beautiful guys
ever.
Like now everyone looks at Mola,
like he's the fucking are not a lot,
but a lot of lot of people see them as
like a total piece of shit con man.
But I remember Donald Trump tweeting out
when the investigation started,
something like that.
I'm glad it's molar because he's so
respected.
So now all of a sudden,
here's what we're saying about Mueller,
everyone's so scared of Mueller,
Mueller,
rape kids in front of people.
What she did mean,
Mueller covered up for a decade for
Epstein kidnapping kids,
flying them on sex planes.
Some kids as young as seven years old,
reportedly with big perverts raping them
to frame people.
I mean,
Mueller is a monster man.
Cod.
Imagine he's even above the pedophiles
though.
So I mean,
well,
right off the bat,
can you.
I don't know if not that,
if it's hard statements,
if.
I mean you can't really call a guy.
He's like,
do you use straight up watched people
rape kids?
Like that's kind of.
What's the word?
It's a bold claim.
It's not a bold claim.
It's a slander,
frankly speaking.
All right.
You can't just be like,
dude,
I have.
I know.
I know for a fact that Alex Jones
watches people,
rape kids,
that right and strong statement.
Let's keep watching.
I mean,
slander.
I,
all that is slander or does.
He doesn't have sexual kids.
He just controls it all interested in
fucking kids.
He just likes to,
uh,
facilitate
ajit being a monster like that.
God,
all people say,
well God,
you scared of him.
I'm scared of not manning up.
Dude,
are you don't just scared of talking
about this.
Good.
Let's give him one main fear.
I'm not being a real man and I'm not
doing what it takes and I'm not telling
the truth.
And so call it whatever you want.
I look at that guy,
he's a sex offender.
The Danes and I will take down or I'll
try and sell that shit.
Gonna Happen.
We're gonna.
Walk out the square politically high,
noon and he's on to find out what he
makes you move,
man.
Make the move first and then it's going
to happen.
It's not a joke.
That's not a gain.
So real world politically,
you're going to get it or I'm going to
try a bitch.
I didn't notice.
You actually was saying
politically right now.
Yeah.
I don't know.
What does he mean by that?
Well,
it isn't.
It's very.
I mean it's very.
When you're,
when you're accusing somebody of like
basically raping kids.
I mean we hold that in our culture to be
one of the worst things possible to the
point that where you don't even respect
their life.
When you degrade someone to the point of
being a child rapist,
really when you're saying,
Hey,
I'm going to,
I'm going to shoot you.
If somebody goes,
if somebody who believes that he's a
pedophile goes and murders him,
am I like,
if were to believe that he's actually
like organizing a massive pedophile
ring,
how much sympathy do you have for the
guy?
Right.
So this,
this shit you,
you really.
I mean,
I feel like he's just doing a character,
right?
And like a overexaggerating everything
and it could be entertaining when you're
watching it through that Lens,
but from what I understand,
a lot of people take him seriously and
believe that he's believing what he's
saying.
So I don't think he really believes what
he says,
like about all the crazy stuff that he.
Well,
there.
That's definitely debatable.
Um,
hey guys,
uh,
let me cut in real quick it.
Yeah.
Wow.
We uh,
we just got taken down by youtube.
They just killed her stream.
Really?
Yep.
Why?
Community guidelines.
Wow.
We can't even show his footage.
What never been removed.
How stupid are you?
Youtube.
Alright,
we are back.
We were live streaming and bright as we
were getting into it.
You guys saw,
if you're watching the Vod,
youtube in their infinite wisdom teeth
removed our live stream and gave us a
strike,
which basically when you get a strike,
you can't live stream anymore,
so some genius over at live to live.
I'm having a fucking.
I'm not.
You see what it's doing to me,
shredders freaking out.
We've been sitting here for like an hour
trying to figure out what to do.
Some fucking genius was like,
Oh,
they're talking about Alex Jones.
Let's remove the fucking.
You know what it is so insane is that my
whole rant as I was just getting into
was very.
I'm taking Youtube side that Alex Jones
is a crazy conspiracy theorist who
violated the terms of service,
was doing all this shit that shouldn't
buy youtubes terms of service shouldn't
be allowed and what the fuck does
youtube do?
Did like,
you know what we need to do?
They'll sit around and think of what's
the best thing to do right now?
The most best thing they're like will
make us look so much better.
Ethan is defending us.
Ethan,
who's defending us against Alex Jones
right now.
Do you know what we can do in one fell
swoop to legitimize Alex Jones and to
pitch Ethan often turn them against us.
Let's shut as channel down and give them
a strike mid live stream.
It's brilliant.
Let's do that.
Shut it down.
What the fuck?
Like how can I even sit here now and
call Alex Jones,
conspiracy theorists when our child just
got strike down for even fucking talking
about him.
Not even.
I was criticizing him.
We were analyzing the situation.
What are the how?
Who watched that and thought to himself,
this needs to be taken down right now.
I was literally just talking about how
he defamed Robert,
Robert Mueller,
Mueller.
They're like,
dude,
you know what we could do to make the
situation even worse for us.
They're like,
this was like a beautiful play by them
too.
Like in one fell swoop we can turn ethan
against us who's usually critical bus,
but in this time he's defending us.
We can.
Alex Jones was an explosive,
sensitive situation.
Everybody's saying that it's a
conspiracy theory to censor the right
wing media and one fell swoop.
What can we do?
Well,
that's all fit and think I've got it.
Strike their live screaming or remove
their ability to
broadcast.
Let me look at my context.
We do have Ethan's number.
We could reach out to him real quick and
say,
Hey,
I don't even know what they wanted to
say,
but
no,
no.
Let's be reasonable.
You know,
this is so stupid.
I have to say this is so dumb because
now the people that I was criticizing
are going to use this as evidence to
say,
hey,
this is proof.
There's a conspiracy against this after
all,
and you know what?
It's hard for me now to argue against
that.
Do you understand how fucking stupid you
are?
Youtube here.
Let me show you some of my notes and I
was going to talk about.
They even knew that we were going to
talk about it.
They gave you.
I consulted with somebody high up in
Youtube before this episode to get a
statement from them here.
Let me show you some of my notes that a
deborah got to air this.
Never got to air a blast.
What's,
what is it called?
Goddammit.
Slander against molar threats of
violence.
Clear violation of the terms of use.
Sandy Hook was was a crisis actor.
I've got this whole great piece about
that so I can't talk about this now.
How am I going to talk?
Oh,
there's no conspiracy that was fucking
defending you
and now I'm offline.
Nobody's even watching me.
Right?
It's so weird.
It's like,
who are we talking to?
Nobody.
I'm off flying.
I'm off the fricking grid right now.
It's just me,
you
and shredder.
Who's really upset because he hasn't got
walked into frikking hours and it was
supposed to only be here for one hour.
We supposed to be done.
Now.
I even prepared a soundbite.
Destroy the child because I was goofing
on.
Alex Jones,
so much brick and pissed off.
We had this amazing.
It doesn't make any sense now because I
can't go on and on about.
All right,
let me just summarize my points.
Sandy Hook,
crisis.
That's inappropriate.
It was an Anderson Cooper green screen.
The bumped it.
Here's a lawsuit.
Yeah.
Sandy Hook.
Parents are suing,
uh,
suing Alex Jones because they can't
visit their child's grave because
they're being harassed by lunatics.
Oh Wow.
Who Cares?
And the five years since,
uh,
our son was killed.
Death threats.
It online harassment have forced us to
leave the city and relocate seven times.
Wow.
Big Deal or challenged,
discussed,
shut down.
They now live in a high security
community.
A hundred miles away from there were the
six year old was buried.
I love to go see my son's and I don't
get to do that because we made the right
decision to move away.
Destroy the child.
You see I have content.
That story is pretty crazy.
How am I supposed to actually like be
like,
Oh yeah,
I've got all this.
I mean,
I also see a lot of people saying it was
a coordinated attack.
Shut us down.
It doesn't seem that far fetched
anymore.
What do I do?
Do I just show the edit we made?
It's pretty damn good.
It's such a shame not to prepare an
edit.
Well,
okay.
The edit is not really editorialized.
It's really have a memorial dedicated to
Alex Jones channel being removed.
Okay.
It's,
you guys really messed up.
I'm looking over.
I,
I planned this really great segment,
you know,
but I can't,
I can't in good mine.
I can't say it
because I just got shot down.
So with that being said,
we are just going to show you the edit
we made and uh,
in honor of Alex Jones,
who was a,
you know,
a character,
a hilarious guy,
if you will say now it just sounds like
I'm praising him after that whole
fucking list of grievances.
So insane.
And now now look like I hate when this
happens.
Now all of a sudden I always get shit
for being like a right way of fringe,
right wing,
like sympathizer.
And now I'm the.
I continue to be the darling of the
right,
defending Alex Jones.
Why do you put me in this situation?
I am not that I am here to criticize and
defend you.
And now look where it got me.
Oh,
Ethan,
the darling of the.
All right.
Defending Alex Jones.
Thank you for defending everything.
Because you clearly have a point here.
Alright,
fuck sake.
Just roll the edit for Christ sake.
Do I do commercial after that?
Thirteen months.
I know your mustache is cool.
Classes.
I will go to.
Amanda.
Made it start your journey to super male
vitality to stop your ass.
Little Communist.
I'm a human trauma.
He's going to come together.
We know we're under attack.
I never expected trump charging into a
goblins,
Nash to not get some Goblin vomit,
swap and blood on him.
I don't want to see them kissing
goblins.
Spider goats are at least two peer
bashing and because I don't like gay
people,
I don't like putting chemicals in the
water that turn the frigging slobs gay
gay.
It'll take all children at birth and
raised them a government dormitories and
do medical experiments.
Break your jaw in seconds.
Use a synthetic completely fake with
your nose.
Bloody Bolt.
The new town kids,
take them,
put them in our face.
Tell us their names,
who they were.
Do you understand that crap?
The frigging flagged game.
Gay,
gay,
gay.
Thank you to postmates for sponsoring
us.
I cannot endorse postmates enough.
Okay.
Oh,
there's apps that can bring you.
Food mates can bring you food.
It can bring you anything.
I use postmates on a weekly basis.
Let me tell you what I use it for
restaurants that aren't on other apps
that bring you food because basically
the good ones,
the good ones are always not because you
don't have to decide because the
specific driver goes out and picks up
whatever you want.
You need some beers from Ralph's every
fuck it up.
You need some Carl's Jr.
Some taco bell.
Late night or maybe your favorite
reStaurant.
Guess what?
They pick it up.
We actually have a friend who ordered a
mac laptop.
Yeah,
through postmates you can order anything
and that it looks so beautiful.
He was like,
he's a public figure and he's like,
I just realized I don't actually have to
go to the mac store and stand in line
and deal with that whole thing.
I sent a postmates driver to pick me up
a computer.
I've bLack book.
I'm telling you,
this app is unbelievable.
It's a life changing revelation.
Introducing postmates,
the app that adds a delivery option to
your favorite restaurant and more.
You don't have to park.
you don't have to drive.
You don't even have to talk on the
fricking phone.
You tell them what you want in the app.
They come,
they bring it.
Boom.
Bob,
bob's your uncle.
Life has changed forever.
Download the app and order 24 hours a
day,
365 days a year post.
We will bring you what you want within
the hour,
you can even see where your food is or
your computer and you can track your
driver eggs,
milk burgers,
perfect bottle of red wine,
beer,
cigarettes.
They get it all.
All.
I dare you to try to stretch it to the
limit.
Postmates is your new longterm munchies.
Booty call.
They wrote that.
I endorsed that.
I liked that.
And here's the thinG.
You already don't need another reason to
download this godsend of an app
postmates.
Here,
let me give you this limited time offer.
Postmates gives you a $100 of free
delivery credit.
Oh,
can I get that on the house for your
first seven days to start your free
deliveries?
No,
you are.
You're already signed up.
To use the code you're going to have to
rate.
You're going to have to factor and reset
your phone.
It's worth it.
To start your free deliveries,
download the app today and use code h
three.
That's code at age three for $100 of
free delivery credit for your first
seven days.
Save the hassle and get the food.
Get whatever you want.
Whatever you love postmates with code h
three.
Try the fricking app.
I swear to god,
change everything you knew about being
alive.
Postmates dollar shave club has got it
all.
Why are you wasting your time going to
the store?
Picking ouT a shampoo,
picking out a razor,
picking out butt wipes is already all
set up as convenient as possible.
The best products you're going to find
at dollar shave club,
get it together.
All right,
how many times do I have to tell you for
for pizza sake,
join the club,
right?
Nice.
Like a nice ball in the house.
Timing,
dollar shave club.
My dudes,
they got everything you need for the
bathroom.
Yes.
That's dollar shave club.
They deliver it so you can look,
feel,
smell.
You're very dang best.
They've got shampoo,
they've got conditioner,
they've got the bodywash to toothpaste,
they hair gel and even a wipe.
My dudes that is gonna,
keep your ass glistening that When you
bring that special girl home,
you can say,
you know what,
the chinese food tonight,
baby,
we don't need plates because tonight
you're eating my ass somehow that and
tell them you don't want to eat my ass.
I'm a big fan by the way of their.
They've got this amber and lavender body
wash that is smell so good that when
they're eating your app on the way down
to him and be like,
damn,
and that bodywash sent is in st.
Amazing.
Good luck buying a product that great in
store won't happen.
All it does,
dollar shave club's products are made
with top shelf ingredients that won't
break your budget.
You're going to feel the difference.
Shipping is included with your
membership.
You get to buy this stuff anyway,
right?
What are you going to walk around like a
homeless slob?
You've got to make sure your claim,
we'll do it with dollar shave club to do
the best in the gaMe.
You don't hAve to go to the store for
Christ sake.
Here's a great way to strive.
Bunch of dollar shave club products for
just five bucks.
You can get their daily essential
starter kit,
five bucks.
It comes with body cleanser,
one wipe charlie.
TheY're amazing,
but wipes.
They're world famous shave butter and
their best razor.
The six blade executive.
Keep the blades coming for a few bucks a
month and add in shampoo,
toothpaste,
or anything else you need for the
bathroom.
Check it all out@dollarshaveclub.com
slash h three.
That's the dollar shave club.com/h
three.
There is no reason not to join.
get in the fricken club right now.
Sixty six percent of men lose their hair
by age 35.
And when you notice it's going,
it's already too late.
How much easier is it to keep the hair
you have than to try to replace it once
it's gone?
I don't know.
Is that hairline slowly fading back?
How will it feel a year from now?
Is it going to be business as usual or
is your hairline going to be broke just
like you're fucked up life.
I ask you this,
do you want a bald spot
pop up or do you want to do something
about it?
First,
do something.
Do you want your hair to recede or are
you going to do something about it
first,
why you turn into weird solutions or
doing nothing at all?
When you can turn to medicine and
science,
the suspense is building or [inaudible]
dot com is a one stop shop for hair
loss.
Skin care,
sexual wellness for men.
Dan,
show him what it did for you.
Look at dan's beautiful glistening main.
His hair line was receding badly.
What's going way back and now look at
him.
He's basically an anime character.
The fuck's on the daily,
dan is basically people have body
pillows in the image of dan.
Now,
it's true,
thanks to science guys.
Baldness can be optional hymns
connection with real doctors and medical
grade solutions to treat your hair loss.
There's a well known genetic equivalent
to a name brand prescription to help you
keep your hair.
Okay.
These are prescription solutions backed
by science.
There's no waiting room,
no awkward doctor visit.
Save hours by going to [inaudible] dot
com.
So frickin easy answer.
A few quick questions.
Dr [inaudible] review and you prescribe
you your medicine to keep those
beautiful.
Heres plugged right in your damn head.
Products are shipped directly to your
door,
so order now.
My listeners get a trial month of hams
for just $5 today,
right now while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you went to
the doctor or pharmacy and let's not
even talk about time,
which is the most priceless of all
resources available to men,
right?
Saves you that.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash eight.
Three.
That's for him.
[inaudible] dot com slash h three four
[inaudible] dot com slash h three.
Keep that beautiful head of hair.
Don't let it fade away like all your
dreams have to this point in life.
We are back and I am still upset.
Took a little break,
stIll met.
Frankly,
I feel like I'm.
I feel a little bit like this right now.
That's how I feel.
All right
now.
Now I actually did speak with you too
were offline.
Nobody's listening.
I know it's weird,
but we.
So they were moving the strike.
Okay.
We can live stream now,
but I mean obviously we have to finish
offline.
Started already.
We're going to combine the episodes.
They said they were wrong.
It was a mistake.
Whatever that means.
Somebody removed the video.
It wasn't.
If they could.
Let's put it this way.
They.
If they could redo it again,
they would leave the video up.
Somebody is probably getting fired today
promoting.
You think someone's getting fired.
It was just some grunt.
That's how you mistake is that you just
go and give someone a strike and they
have like really up to use rules.
It's like some grunt who's making $10 an
hour in India for all I know.
You know what I'm saying?
And it's like these,
these low.
This is how youtube format and it's just
so ridiculous that Alex Jones video.
Yeah,
they.
They saw it as a re upload and not
somebody talking about it.
Obviously you could talk about it,
so they said it was a mistake,
but like this is a problem with how
youtube formats to their company.
It's so ridiculous.
There's some,
some ridiculous.
Shut down our stream.
They know us.
They have our phone number.
They know we were going to talk about
it.
It's like you guys never went,
never went beyond,
you know,
an 18 year old dudes.
First job who's making $10 an hour,
who was just like,
I got reported or this matches Alex
Jones content that shouldn't be
uploaded.
He opens it and he's like,
you know what?
Fuck this guy.
It's like,
damn,
come on ya'll.
All right.
I don't know how to move on and how
it's.
I don't know how we're going to talk
about a score it in a aqap god squirting
and a cup so upset that were offline
right now and the whole episode is so
weird now because like we're like,
how do you talk about something else?
I'm going to try.
Let's get off this.
So the other week I went to a fertility
clinic because we're trying to have a
kid.
We don't know what we've been,
you know,
we've been trying to been trying to
fucking knock you up for like how long?
I don't know.
I'm just fucking
make some damn babies.
Sometimes I wonder.
I'm like,
shit,
maybe.
I see friends with kids and I'm like,
damn,
I don't know if I want married.
It's not.
Maybe we shouldn't do this dog.
I do like this late at night of sleep.
I don't like it was too much.
But at night I'm prefer to sleep.
I love sleep.
We have friends with kids.
They're like,
it's been two years.
yeah,
we don't have a.
Yeah,
I hate my life.
They're like,
oh,
kids are the best.
Meanwhile,
kids are the best thing you'll ever do.
Meanwhile it's like,
yeah,
I didn't get any sleep.
I have to leave every time we hang out
at 3:00
PM.
I've tried praying to escape my family
for any.
For five minutes at a time.
Yeah.
It's really great.
So anyway,
why do we all want to do it to
ourselves?
Why do you want,
why do we want kids?
Like what is wrong with us?
It's just we have a shredder is perfect.
Yeah.
He's a perfect angel.
Like as perfectly as could be.
I remember how happy we were when we
left them at home for like,
or we took them to the groomer yesterday
for like three hours and we left them at
the groomer.
I'm still paranoid about what happened
in those three hours though.
We weren't with him.
Yeah.
I have a fear that they put a finger up
his ass or something in a weird way
because this dark rumors.
I'm telling you the truth.
Our groomers are fucking weird.
The woman who receives him doesn't have
teeth.
She's literally toothless,
which she has like a nub,
but it's not in the way in her mouth,
but it's not a weird.
It's like a really nice place.
Yes.
But I have to say main local area.
Like it's not like we're taking him to a
weird place.
We're taking him to a nice place.
Right.
Five star reviews or whatever,
but in my mind if I were to imagine,
okay,
lady,
the fuck's dogs.
That's what I would imagine.
I think she goes shut.
Has this move when he cuddles with you
that he looks inside your ear?
Yeah,
and so she goes,
she says to me,
what?
I just don't want.
I know where you're going with it and no
one this thought in my head.
Well I don't know what happened,
but she says to me when we went to pick
them up,
she was like,
oh,
that's his mobile phone.
That he licks in the ears.
I was like,
that sounds like shutter,
but I'm also like,
what situation is he?
Why is he up there?
What was she doing?
Was she.
Why was he is capable of putting his
tongue and our ear.
You're thinking he gives good head
five.
You're thinking.
No,
but I was always afraid that you're
going to say that she was enjoying it or
something.
That's not.
I'm not.
I'm not that.
He doesn't like peanut butter,
natural food that imagine what her mouth
looks like.
Imagine what her job looks
like.
No,
probably got rotting teeth in the I.
no,
no.
So and so for,
at any rate,
imagine having a kid.
You leave your dog for three hours,
have to sick thoughts you have in your
mind.
So anyway,
I went to,
I went to a for tenor,
for tilty clinic to analyze my semen.
It's a funny situation that I wanted to
talk about,
by the way,
checks out my sIemens great.
Let me normal.
It wasn't like,
dude,
you're assuming that the duck is like
your semen is insane,
bro.
That's normal.
Said it's normal.
That's dank.
You're seen as normal.
That's dang.
So anyway,
you go to this little so it's just this
little office.
they bring into this back a little room
and they bring you into this room and
they're like,
all right,
well here's a cup.
you jerk and do and when you're done you
bring it out and there's like a little,
you know,
little window you open and then you put
the cup in and you close it and I guess
some other person back there gargles it
and the same.
It's fine.
You know,
whatever they do.
And then I didn't even think about this
stuff.
That would be funny though,
because you imagine there's like
advanced machinery and they looking at
it under a telescope,
but it's just some fucking weirdo
gargles up like it's a little on the
weak side.
I think it is.
Advanced Machinery.
Yeah.
It's just a funny thought.
Hilo.
Anyway,
I walked into the room and I was.
So I was just repost.
I had,
I took a bunch of pictures of the room
that I want to show you guys.
So let me,
let me open that up.
Where's all this shit?
My desktop can go away.
Fuck off.
Oh my god.
Anyway,
so here squirting.
And the cup pictures got a slideshow for
you guys.
So here's the room.
Oh,
hello.
Okay.
So here's the realm I want to describe
it for audio listeners.
So this.
So,
so basically now what you're looking at
his headphones that are plugged in to
the tv.
Okay.
Now look next to it at the wall there's
trips running down the wall,
like some dudes just jerked all over the
wall and there's stains on the
headphones are on the ground.
It's like imagine putting those on your
head and why is it on the ground?
You'd look.
Look dude,
there's a huge drip look by the left
headphone.
There's like a wet drip there.
You see that right here.
I'll put the mouse over it.
You see this is a splurge strip.
Oh,
you don't see it?
Oh look,
there's this.
Hold on right here.
Oh,
so.
Okay.
So I was like,
holy shit.
Yeah.
So these are like,
they've got like playboys and stuff and
this.
Imagine touching that.
The sticky assets white.
Oh,
it's coming.
It's magazines.
It's on the wall and hustlers and shit.
But like this has been handled by
thousands of dudes who have jerked
before.
You imagine touching that feeling.
You got to wear like a hazmat suit when
you walk into this room.
I dropped.
I was like,
when I walked in,
we'll wait till you see the chair.
Yeah,
just the look of this chair.
That's the first thing you see when you
walk in the room.
Looks like a torture chair.
Crazy.
It's like a pee pad,
like striders pee pads.
It's like,
it's like you to do it.
That's fine,
I'll totally jerk off in that chair.
Now that you've covered it with it's a
pee pad.
What to do and they expect the year like
get naked and sit on that.
I don't know.
You got to do what you gotta do.
That's the only chair in the room.
I did a standing up.
I just dropped trial and I just got.
I just banged it out a little quick.
No matter how much in this chair was
covered,
I would not say it on it.
No,
I was horrified when I walked in.
That's when I decided to get my camera.
When I saw this chair,
I was like,
this is unbelievable.
What do they expect that you're going to
jerk off onto the chair?
I dunno.
You know,
some weird dudes are into this.
They probably don't even.
They do this every week.
They really don't even need the
analysis.
It just turns them on what?
This is.
So gross.
Here's the cup.
So you crack it open,
you do the deed and then you have to put
the exact time you squirted.
So it was like 1153 and you know the
exact minute.
And what is it that,
because it's so huge,
because I guess,
you know,
over time the semen degrades.
So lIke the minute matters.
I like it.
It's like right next to the tv remote.
So potentially my semen could be even
stronger and they were just a couple
minutes off.
Right?
Imagine touching anything in that room.
So they've got a tv with like porn on it
and you can put the headphones off and
sit in the chair and jerk off,
which is insane.
I just stood right there.
I scored it All over the fucking chair
and everything.
No,
I did look at this trashcan full of rag.
Oh my god.
They don't even emPty.
That's what it was when I walked in.
Just fall.
Rags,
like at least trashcan we to toP up.
Close up.
Why would it had funds on the ground?
Yeah,
I mean there's just a little.
So here's the situation.
Some lube,
a tiny really old tv.
I mean,
gosh didn't,
does that.
It cost money to do this.
Yeah,
it was like 200 bucks.
So what's with the shoot it wrong?
They don't even have money for like a
nicer tv stand.
It's all.
It's all going to be on this tiny look.
I don't know what you know.
I know ladies needs some kind of
romancing.
I literally,
I was like,
listen,
I'm here.
I fucking dropped trial it.
I probably was in and out.
Okay.
No sound.
One minute.
I didn't want to spend another second in
there just by being in there with my
dick out.
I thought I was going to get worse oral
thing.
Empty.
It looks empty.
It's very low.
You will get a lot of use.
I mean just imagine like imagine this,
you're about to jerk off with this lube
and you have to touch.
Even the act of squirting it out.
It's like they're not aware of how gross
I need to go in there and like a full
body condom.
That's it.
That's my tour of the.
I can't believe ya.
But then the weird thing is like you go
in the room and then you,
you do it in the cup and you bring it
out and then you have to go back in the
lobby,
meet the merck,
the nurse.
So you let go and you face thIs middle
aged woman who's just turned it off and
then you go to bailing and some old
ladies like here's your,
here's your bill for jerking off.
So weird.
Like in what situation can you just.
Everyone knows you're jerking off and
it's all good.
Here's the interesting thing.
So we all did our test.
Everything is normal so maybe we should
just not have a kid because it's a sign
from god.
Just don't let me back in that room.
It's crazy.
It's a crazy thing.
Yeah.
You just sheepishly walk out.
They sit your ass in another lobby and
everyone's staring at you.
Like to just jerked off.
That's what you feel like it was
looking.
Oh no,
they do it all day.
They don't even care.
No,
they don't care.
What if they ever see a guy like walk
out and there's like some jazz on a shoe
or something?
Probably they probably seen that small
room.
It's like they don't.
There's no room for error in there.
Right.
Pretty wild stuff.
Um,
we wanted to talk about youtube stream
podcast.
It's hard to get bAck into it.
I'm exhausted because we'd been here for
like five hours.
I'm like,
I'm worthless after a couPle of hours
when we do these.
My voice is already hurting from talking
so much.
We've just,
we haven't even started.
Alright.
EPisodes sucks.
What else?
We got ajit pi.
It's hard to go on.
I'm exhausted.
We've got the segment from ian.
Yeah,
I think we'll have to.
We're going to axion segment.
Should we just bring them out and do a
segment?
let's just,
let's just get through this.
Let's see.
Let's,
let's slam through it.
Ajit pi.
He's back.
Oh,
I can't muster the strength to care
about this.
I just realized.
How long has this been,
dan?
Um,
well,
because all of the starting and
stopping.
A little tough to say.
Let's see,
uh,
probably just about an hour.
The episodes an hour long.
Oh my god.
It feels like we've been here for like a
week.
yeah,
I think we're actually probably under an
hour or even.
Oh my god.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
I mean the longest hour episode ever.
We've been recording for a 16 minutes
since we came back in from the sponsor
read and I think we broke it.
The 35 minute mark sponsor reads about
five minutes long.
So yeah,
about an hour.
Ajit pi.
You guys remember this fucking idiot.
This idiot.
Let me show you.
This face has got the most goofy has
goddamn face.
And I say that only because he's such an
asshole.
Actually it was facing the article
you're going to open is funnier.
Is it?
See,
so ajit pi,
the chairman of the fcc lied to congress
about allegedly cyber attacks.
That didn't actually happen.
So when you guys remember this huge
battle for net neutrality,
we actually made a podcast about it to.
Oh,
let me show this.
You mean this one here?
I love the framing of that shot.
Can't talk.
You can't ever complain.
Oh,
that's a bad photo of me.
When like your,
your actual headshot looks like this,
like this guy just,
he looks goofy in every photo.
Come on,
like that's his,
that's the picture on the wall.
So
this is the guy I don't remember.
We've talked about him.
So ajit pi during this huge raging
debate about net neutrality,
um,
god,
I can't muster the strength to care
about this is this so hard?
So I mean it is what it is.
We don't have to do the failed episode.
What we planned is not anYmore
anyway.
They said they got so many people that
were like,
fuck you,
I want net neutrality that their website
crashed.
And they were like see how bad we want
net neutrality.
And the fcc was like,
actually you guys have greatly
exaggerated how many people have come
because the reason our website got shut
down is because we were hacked and ddoss
attacked by people trying to make it
look like there was more people than
there were.
So they just made a bright light because
these such a little fucking bitch look
at the house.
Like how
does,
is there a whole team that has to agree
on that statement?
Yes ma'am.
And they all agreed.
So at first came out by like their their
tech person and then ajit pi boy came
out and did a press conference in front
of congress and said we were ddoss
attack.
Now everybody knows about tech was
looking at it and being like,
there's no evidence.
We're almost certain that didn't happen.
and he came to the point where it was
pretty much proven that they will never
d dos attack.
So we're,
theY're now forced to just recently,
August 8th to admit that they lied about
an alleged cyber attack that didn't
actually ever happened because they
looked like such idiots.
This,
and I'm not surprised this is the guy
who made those videos about net
neutrality in his santa suit.
So when do they get any kind of
punishment for lying about it and in a
sane world,
but my friend that is far from the world
we live in,
but just know that this.
He got a pie in the face but it's not
the first and won't be the last one.
This,
I think this guY's just use them cream
all over his face.
You know what I'm saying?
Yep.
If his face got creamed anymore,
he'd looked like the chair in that
office.
Do you know what I'm saying?
I know I got through that store.
What else would go film academy awards.
New category at the academy.
What do you call those?
The oscars.
Yeah,
the oscars new category at the oscars.
Outstanding achievement and popular film
because all the popular films never get
nominated because it's all this art
bullshit that nobody's fucking watched.
By the way.
I kind of agree like the shape of water.
Who cared about that movie?
I don't understand.
Yeah,
I know.
The one before was one day before it was
like moonlight,
which was like the super like,
I know it's 10 people saw that.
I haven't seen that one,
so I can't tell,
but I saw when I was traveling to
Israel,
I got to watch a bunch of movies,
so I saw the shape of water and I was
like,
what?
Who cares?
Got the movie.
She fucks a fish.
She falls in love with him for no
reason.
It's like the.
The storY was so weird.
I haven't seen it,
but isla has a really good thing going
on.
Like,
how's it going?
Let me get this straight.
It's a chick flick.
It's about the power of love when a
bitch can be.
Sorry,
I shouldn't say it like that.
I should've framed like that when a girl
I didn't make a bit.
not a bit.
She's like,
yeAh,
I just mean that in like the colloquial
sense,
but I shouldn't say that.
So when a sweet young,
lovely,
misunderstood.
Yeah.
Because she can't talk.
She's so misunderstood.
She's mute.
That true love can still find you in end
and the form of a giant fish cock.
It looks like a fish monster or
whatever.
Tell me.
Does she actually fuck them?
They actually have sex.
Ahab biologically caPable of having sex
and she does it in an aPartment that is
not hers.
She fills up Then.
I mean,
I don't know if this is like your family
is going to get upset for me spoiling
the shooting movie,
but nobody cares.
Um,
she fills up the bathroom with water
boiler that they fuck.
I don't know.
I mean I knew about it before I watched
the movie,
so I don't think so.
everyone has talked about it already and
if there's a sexual act,
do they do with the gills?
no,
he,
she,
they acknowledged that he has like an.
Yeah,
they went out.
Did they ever acknowledge it?
How Big it is?
No,
but she fills up the bathroom with the
water so that they can swim together.
The Bathroom?
Yeah.
She fills up the room with a water hose
possible.
Not possible.
And then you need to do movie reviews.
This is great.
Then the water is leaking?
Well,
no,
the whole Building.
So let me get this straight.
Somehow.
She's a hero.
She didn't care about everyone else in
the building.
Celebrated when she destroys this whole
bill floods,
this whole building so she can get a
little selfish dick because she's so
pathetic and lonely.
She can't go over to the corner bar to
the dive.
I get some dick the normal way.
Yes.
And we're giving her academy award.
Isla,
you need to do movie reviews.
You're such a hater,
like in a great way.
Did we need holy shit.
So anyway.
Outstanding achievement in popular film.
It's kind of a slap in the face though
too.
It's Like it's not a real category.
It's like fast and furious.
Is the winter fast and furious.
Twenty one is the winner and outstanding
achievement and popular film.
Everyone stands up and claps.
So like fake ass award.
They've been.
They've been given examples.
Movies like the guardians of the galaxy
and the star wars films.
We've been nominated for both in this
new category and best picture.
However,
the intent of this category is to honor
more popular blockbuster type movies a
lot.
The avengers or star wars.
I mean,
look,
if you can't make a gooD movie that's
popular,
both like lord of the rings one,
I'm surprised star wars doesn't win
anything.
Well,
you remember star lord of the rings wAs
like sweePing every year because guess
what?
It's Popular and good.
Yeah,
lots popular.
Can good.
Makes it the best.
And that's when you,
when this new categories fucking
everything up,
because no longer can you like popular
and good,
god forbid,
and you know what it is,
it enables hollywood to be even more
shits.
That's true because they're gonna be
like,
whoa,
well we'll win this shitty nominee.
Biggest fucking waste of time or biggest
like they also enabling them.
They also are going to make the award
show shorter because they acknowledged
that it's boring and no one is watching
down to a mere three hours from.
For me,
I'm an hour and a half in this podcast
and I'm dying expecting to walk your
fucking show for three goddamned our
other Washington.
I'd rather watch her have sex with her
fish for three hours.
He's like a fish.
God fish god.
He's probably.
But they never explained why they never
show like what's so good about him,
his fucking car.
they explicitly referred to him as a
godless being what it is that god.
Yeah,
he's a fish.
Got there.
Like what makes him a god?
They're like 15 inches.
It's just so like,
typically there's like this evil man,
which is one of whom are no reason,
no reason,
and then she's the only one who sees to
butte in him stupid.
It's got to be a button for this
destroyed.
There's no context.
And then we did the bit to Alex Jones
saying the edit.
yeah,
we did.
I could do a movie review.
I hate being late.
I hate 90 percent of all movies.
I don't know if it's a new segment for
the h three videos that you live movie
reviews so and say,
well let's start on the podcast.
I've embarrassed and it's kind of like
the,
the segment that I hate on jimmy kimmel,
except that you're actually coherent
having an opinion.
He's just doing nonsense.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean he just ran some incoherently and
it's just because he has an accent.
You're like a glorious hater.
Like you are dismantling this dumb ass
video.
Like that's a beautiful thing.
I'll think about it.
I,
I anyWay,
but you know,
you guys judge for yourself,
but I do fear that like,
but you guys are going to hate me
because I hate movies.
Do you like probably so good though,
but you can't hate it because you're so
lovable.
All right.
what else?
We got amazon glasses.
My throat is actually hurting for like
10 hours.
Amazon is patented some goggles and by
the you know,
yada yada yada.
The workers,
they were.
it's augmented reality so they work more
effectively.
Here's a picture they look like ski
goggles and their warehouses so big that
they need to create goggles that gives
you.
It's like a gps.
It tells you turn left turn right
to get the product.
Speculate that this tech is actually
being used to train deep learning ai so
that they can eventually throw out all
these fucking loser as humans and just
have robots doing it.
Interesting.
What's next?
We're so fuck when there's no jobs left.
you know what I'm saying?
Anyway,
I don't really believe in that because
there will be new jobs.
Can you know there is a problem.
I mean like historically it's like
people don't ride horses anymore,
so,
but then a new youtube videos.
Yeah.
Well,
how many people can youtube higher?
No,
but I mean there's new jobs.
I know,
but it's like before,
but it's shrinking because automation
automation was ever a problem with
shifting fields.
It was like,
oh,
we don't need people to raise horses,
but now we're building cars and it's a
new field or like you don't need people
digging coal up,
but now there's all these people on
renewable energy.
Exactly.
But automation is a different issue
because it's literally replacing people
of every job.
Yeah.
And so all because you got to order your
cute tips in one day shipping from
amazon instead of walking into a roth
five minutes away from your house.
Did you know?
We're guilty of that every date.
What else?
We got ian,
you want to do this presentation for
christ sake?
Little uzi.
Here's another ian put together a
segment for us.
Lil uzi vert,
who's a hip hop rapper.
you raps.
He,
um,
he ripped off or let's not say ripped
off.
He got inspired by the art of heaven's
gate cult.
If you guys don't remember these sweet,
very inspired and creative individuals.
the heaven's gate cult.
They were the guys you guys may recall
when haley bop came around,
which is this comment that comes around
earth about every 2000 years or so.
Dan,
is that correct me if I'm wrong,
approximately.
Yeah,
that's right.
And um,
hail bottom hale bob sounds like such a
great news.
I kind of already with haley bop,
bop.
Anyway,
these dudes,
they act,
you know,
drinking the koolaid.
But these are the guys,
they,
that's their main.
Their,
they originally there the original
correlate drink?
No,
they were a applesauce aisle.
No.
Are you sure it is a johnstone
different,
different goal.
God,
can we retake this?
What did they do in that?
Both sides put poison sinai.
Well,
there night they had these sweet ass
nike's,
right?
I did hear about the nike's.
Yes.
So they all were wearing,
looking like,
so fresh,
like ultimate sneaker heads of these
guys.
And they had these fresh.
Yes,
nike's on.
And um,
they ate this apple sauce with poison in
it.
And they all said,
smell you later or and in there,
they believe that hailey bop,
bop,
whatever.
Fucking haley.
Bob haley.
Bob is bob.
What is it,
dan?
I believe it's hale bob hale.
Bob.
We'd pee.
We hit that.
Be hard at the end.
Or is it a piece?
Are we pronounced hale bopp for fact
checking this right now,
bob.
We got the kids.
Yeah,
kidding.
By the expert.
You can get him in there.
So hale bopp not yet.
Hale bopp comes around every 2000 years
and they thought there's an alien
spaceship.
The mothership that cruises behind the
comment.
And if they kill themselves when it's
close to the earth,
they go up to the spectrum.
I didn't know why they are.
Why are they so eager to get on that
spaceship in?
We'll be able to answer that for us.
What's going on on that spaceship that's
so dope.
Parties.
I love that.
They were all like,
we've determined that this nike is the
freshest.
We want to bring these,
but I wonder if today would be easiest
or what.
No,
they're like,
these yeezys are the fresh issue for
eternity.
It's too hard to get.
So what is some guys are going to be
hard it to get 10 years.
These are you kidding me?
Anyway.
Um,
so they died and,
but,
and so anyway,
there's two of them that they left
behind to maintain the website,
which is hilarious in its own right.
So here is um,
their original art here.
Heaven's gate,
which is pretty sick honestly.
What does it say?
As was promised the keys to heaven's
gate are here again in that font is kind
of tricky.
And to and do the u of o two as they
were in jesus and his father 2000 years
ago.
Oh,
I guess there are theories that it
passed.
Last time it passed was when jesus was
alive.
So he jumped on up to the spaceship.
What kind of dumb ass plot is that of
jesus?
To be like,
yo,
I came to this planet to create life and
die for all your sins.
But guess what?
My spaceship only comes around every
2000 years you're going to be wearing
now.
Can't be wearing the freshest shoes to
know jesus was the ultimate sneakerhead.
I love that.
Graphic design is insane.
And like the gate looks like a key so I
don't.
It's so good.
So,
and his new album art was here.
I'll show you obviously like,
I don't know if you want to call it a
parody,
but obviously really heavily inspired by
it and frankly it's so sick there.
is this better?
Yeah,
there's was like ultimate freshness as
was promised.
The keys to eternal outtake are here and
love and rage the ufo to as little use
vert and his father 2000 years ago.
Anyway,
I love iT.
I think it's great what he did.
But guess who didn't?
Heaven's gate who removed by the way,
I probably have a chip on their shoulder
because all their fucking homies or
cruise a ufo with jesus.
I've been a crazy party with these like
crazy sneakerhead party.
So there,
there you got a chip on their shoulder
and franklin and blame them.
So they're threAtened to sue a little
uzi vert.
And,
um,
that kInd of leaves us off
worth ian,
who as you know,
is the keeper of culture and knowledge
here to report on the huge drama that
has been sending shockwaves throughout
the hip hop community and the earth at
large.
Um,
he's even been in touch with their
surviving to cult members.
He's been in contact.
He has communications with them.
So with that being said in,
please,
you're actually,
I think you were supposed to come in
already if I'm being frank with you.
Hit him with the stinger.
Oh,
you're waiting for me.
Alrighty.
Okay.
So,
um,
as you guys are setting that up,
kind of kind of botched the timing a
little bit.
God,
jesus christ.
Oh,
what happened?
You have an excuse.
What do we think about?
What happened?
Are you blaming daddy's faded out and
spit it out.
What's on your mind?
there's clearly something on your mind
that you're wanting to say.
So if you have an excuse for what's for
this,
tell me what's on your mind.
What's on my mind is heaven's gate.
All right,
you're going to Play it.
Cool.
That's fine.
But this was good at,
you know,
burning the time.
Okay.
All right.
Well,
so here we go.
So ian has put together and his classic
form a powerpoint presentation once
again is the keeper of culture and
knowledge we've been loved and
powerpoints should we love very much,
which is the intersection doesn't cross
very frequently.
The powerpoint and the keeper of color
and youth culture.
He is putting in power often not
crisscrossing.
I want to bring powerpoints into the
mainstream a little more.
I'm glad to hear that.
A great format.
So with that being said in,
please lead us on a bizarre journey into
outer space and beyond.
Okay.
Thank you.
Uh,
aliens.
Colton,
hip hop and investigation by the intern.
That is me.
Uh,
you kind of prefaced a lot
of it,
you know,
but I had a little backstory with lil
uzi vert,
grammy nominated wrapper six times
platinum.
Hit single xo tour life a cultist duly
no.
All this is the question that I'm
seeking the answer.
Thank you.
Yeah.
I had to pay extra for the emoji pack,
you know,
for the powerpoint.
No,
no,
no.
How to png.
And what's that anymore?
Uh,
so on July 6th,
this is where it all started.
Lil uzi vert changes his instagram
profile picture to the following the
leader.
This is,
yeah.
This squidward squidward looking fella.
Look at that face and tell me that too.
It is not a spaceship with jesus,
right?
The f now that guys will colyer.
Yeah.
He's a guy.
Could get Behind.
I think also an interesting note.
Who's these only following one person
and it's a marilyn manson.
Just dramatic.
Yeah,
it's interesting.
So that's what kicked it off.
And then on july 30,
first he releases his album,
cover the one you mentioned there.
And Then on August 1st he tweets the
following.
Uh,
I never really worry because I will
definitely transfer to another body.
Please come with me.
I'm part of the new movement of which
those are some ideas from heaven's gate.
So do you.
Okay.
I'm interested.
I didn't know that he was actually.
Yeah,
he did.
He get the memo because that comment
doesn't come around for bet.
Well that's what I asked them about as
well.
Let's not get,
I mean,
I'm gonna let you do your thing.
I'm captivated though.
It is interesting.
Lucy wants to ride the mothership
because he didn't just grab the graphic.
He's actually saying,
you know,
like transferring to another body or
some of their beliefs.
So,
uh,
what all this mean.
So All this mean what all this means we
need to know.
So there's them side by side.
Uh,
the bottoms there,
like,
uh,
here again in 10 doe,
those were the names of the two leaders.
Doe was the squidward looking man.
OkaY.
She passed away and then he kinda went a
little loopy.
That was his wife or significant other.
They were the cult leaders together.
He believes like it says,
as they were in jesus 2000 years ago,
he believes that he is jesus.
That guy's jesus.
Yeah.
And he's trying to get back to god.
not like he was actually him,
but he's been possessed by an alien
spirit that also possessed jesus.
Two thousand years ago.
Oh damn.
So jesus was possessed by an alien,
found people,
took them up and then came back 2000
years later.
Wow.
And grabbed a couple more.
so that's,
that's the belief system there.
I got to say design wise that ge really
nestled into that queue whole way better
than that.
It definitely does.
Someone pointed out to me as well that
the green bay packers kind of stole the
logo to the g.
It's like the same,
gee,
these guys are prolific designer.
Like this design is kind of next level.
Insane.
No,
it's great bringing me up,
man.
Yeah.
Also like the,
I have to say the curvature of the earth
is really accurate.
Yeah.
That's powerful curve curvature of a
huge planet earth.
But it loosely on there.
Then he went a little too much
curvature.
Yeah.
It's more of like a table class.
So this is the guy marshall applewhite.
Applewhite.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Because then he had them all killed
themselves with apple sauce.
I thought it was inspired with a fun
little easter egg.
So here's a clip of him.
Your only chance to evAcuate is to leave
with us.
It looks like you've been drink lots of
water,
Planet earth,
acid with a about to be recycled.
Your only chance to.
He doesn't blink,
blink,
survive.
Graduate is to lead.
He recorded these taPes
kind of as a way to get people on board
and up to speed.
Oh,
this is a recruitment technique.
Well,
yeah.
So yeah,
in march of 1997,
38,
members of the heaven's gate call eight,
poison applesauce killed themselves and
to board the comment and uh,
they all put on identical outfits and
matching nike decades before the deed.
So I Have a picture of that in this next
one.
A fresh or they have a little patch.
Oh yeah.
They designed that patch as well and
they all had it on their shoulders,
sec,
uh,
the nike's or discontinued and
incredibly rare few pairs on ebay
regarding,
for around $800.
Right now it's pretty ordinary.
The shoe,
the shoe itself isn't that nice?
But yeah,
it's interesting how that's appealing.
But uh,
yeah,
the remaining members are threatening
legal action.
Now.
Hold on,
I'm in.
I'm fascinated by the fact that some of
these guys were left behind apple juice
or not to chug that.
You know what I'm saying?
Yeah,
yeah.
They're left behind specifically to do a
cup just to maintain the website.
Yeah,
I asked them about that.
Uh,
am I getting ahead of myself?
Do you have.
you have.
We're good.
All right.
So this is their website,
like as it looks today,
it hasn't changed since 1997 motif.
Yeah.
they really stuck with it.
So I was just saying,
I spoke with remaining member to get
some clarification.
So my first thing I said,
how do you heard of [inaudible] before?
What do you think of his music?
Who designed the original logo is pretty
high catching.
They said,
uh,
we did not hear of him before the 31st.
Very sPecific.
We know nothing of his music.
It was designed by a couple members of
the group in the spring of [inaudible]
96.
So a year before they all said,
yeah,
I'll took off.
This is not the first time musician has
cooperated heaven's gate,
uh,
in 2016 frank ocean use the same imagery
for his song nike's.
So here's a picture from his music
video.
Uh,
and I was like,
what do you think of people using it?
and you can see the,
uh,
the bed there and the nike shoes.
That's that picture.
Yeah.
Oh,
what they're going to come on,
dude.
I was just curious to attribute.
Yeah.
So I said,
yeah.
Do you find it upsetting or are you glad
to see that heaven's gate is impacting
and popular culture?
What is the appeal?
Really good questions.
I was getting curious.
They sent me a whole a,
they understand that it's pervaded the
culture,
but frank ocean was not infringing on
logos so,
so they're not upset,
but guys are like very business oriented
business,
very business.
They don't mess around.
Can we just acknowledge this is kind of
insane?
That means having a conversation.
yeah.
Yeah.
It was.
Where did he touch with them?
They have you can reach out.
That's all they do is answer emails.
that's damn one of their main thing.
They dOn't have a job.
They do.
I don't say what.
No.
I have an idea of what it may be,
but they didn't explicitly say,
what's your idea?
Does that later can't waIt?
So they told me that they weren't
bothered by that.
They know that their information is
controversial.
Artists reflect the social discussion.
Many are interested in the inner
information and that the generation z
group wants to learn more and are not as
put off as others have been over 21
years.
We're not here to waste our time.
Eventually they want to see the planet
and breakthrough with their information.
We're not here to harm mankind.
We are here to educate and inform.
so,
uh,
I said you were mentioning that you were
hoping to see the planet.
I've come to understand that the next
level,
that's kind of what they call heaven is
only accessible every 2000 or so years
with the passing of the comment.
is that the only way to get there,
it's estimated to return in the year
4,380.
What are your plans for the next 2000,
362 years?
Uh,
are you,
are you planning on just spraying the
teachings throughout the next two
millennium is by way of reincarnation
because they believe in reincarnation.
They kind sassed me a little bit here.
Really?
Where did you get the idea that we time
ourselves to space debris,
so hold on,
wait,
the comment of space debris that.
yeah,
apparently the comment isn't the ufo.
The ufo is behind it in like a jet
stream,
but he's saying that the ufo can come
around anytime he says the next level
created this universe and can come and
go whenever and wherever they choose.
We don't know when they will return but
will be less than 900 or so years.
So there'll be so not worried.
So they just click $900 where they.
What did you get the eye?
I love some space debris.
Yeah,
simple mortal.
The other.
I was a dumb ass for thinking this a.
I love that they say we don't know when
it will return,
but it will be within 900 years.
Yeah,
no worries.
Yeah.
Nathan fielder would just be like,
okay.
I said when the members left for the
next level,
what was the conversation like in which
you were instructed to stay behind?
How maNy were asked to stay?
Did you feel reluctance or possibly
relief?
Whoa,
whoa.
I'm curious.
And they said there were no
conversations.
We received our instructional,
all the group departed by 6:00
PM on March 24th.
There were no options.
Just instruction.
Sounds kinda east.
There's some baggage there.
Yeah,
they didn't really.
They just kind of said,
okay,
this is what we're told and we'll have
to do it.
But this guy,
there's some real.
Do you think there's some underneath
just like we're just loyal soldiers and
we just got an instruction and follow
it.
yeah.
But like you can tell there's some
resentment there.
You think.
I mean if the 39 people are going to
like this space paradise,
there has to be and,
but we need you to stay behind and duke
just like,
fuck you.
Like they're all doing their thing,
you know what I'm saying?
He's,
he's worshiping the next level.
Yeah.
We need somebody To.
Somebody asked me to stay the night
extra to maintain the website.
I'm upset.
Imagine 900 years.
Yeah.
But who's going to watch like lil uzi
vert and see what he's up to us.
How many were left behind and how will
you reach the next level?
Uh,
they said eight were left behind,
five have died of natural causes,
but completed their tasks in 1997,
98.
We two are left in Arizona and one is in
los angeles.
Uh,
we will rejoin them in a classroom
situation at some point in time through
carnation classroom situation.
What does that mean?
I have no idea.
We will reincarnate and rejoined them at
classroom situation.
Yeah.
So I'll just chill in class.
Breakfast clubs,
shredder mess.
Yeah.
So I don't know what the classroom.
And I love this guy.
How this is kind of an old guy.
Must be right.
It's a couple.
Um,
the,
the couple that live in Arizona,
I think I'm jumping from one to the
other in these responses.
Oh yeah.
they must be on the older side,
like sixties maybe because the cold,
the cold started around the seventies.
So theY speak kind of like old people.
Yeah,
exactly.
Michelle emojis.
I asked him,
is your primary directive to manage the
website and answer inquiries?
Do you have other duties?
I was reading some of the guidelines for
the group and they're really restrictive
down to like they were instructing how
big your pancakes could be.
A just for dietary purposes,
do you have hobbies outside of heaven's
gate?
Maybe your favorite movie,
your favorite album?
I was hoping that they'd given me
something.
Yeah.
or like we love like nacho libra or
something,
but uh,
some did internet stuff,
media coverage.
One was assigned to production tasks
with filmmakers that didn't work out.
I actually found that story.
There was a producer to make the film
and he went on tv and was talking about
it and he was on probation for a auto
theft and they saw him on television in
California with the coal and immediately
went and arrested him.
That's where it fell through.
So we worked fulltime,
still pay for everything and take care
of the group affairs all the other
times.
So no hobbies?
No.
Any of the dutIes of providing
information,
just very focused on their beloved.
The how forthcoming they are though.
They just did whatever you want,
man.
You got to ask.
Uh,
so.
And they got back to you pretty quick,
right?
What is this?
Yeah,
they're very faster responding.
So I found that when they w before
everyone went on the spaceship,
they,
the way they made money was actually a
lot of them were programmers and so this
was their old website called higher
source that they would have a use to get
programming jobs.
And This is on the way back machine in
1997.
I don't think it's there anymore.
So I just looked at what type of
websites they designed.
And if you go on their website design
tab,
here's the list of stuff they've done.
I clicked on one of them.
This is prima donna.
They designed this website for a
unauthorized madonna cd was not a thing
on it.
It's madonna,
but it's like a bootleg and someone
hired them to sell this bootleg cd and
this pretty awesome website here.
So that's how they got their money.
Uh,
it's interesting looking at all these
old websites.
I'm wondering sitting on like a small
fortune from these madonna bootlegs.
I'm sure it was a big business and still
working a job.
Somebody's got to bay hosting bill.
They are working day jobs.
Right.
So I read about the website design.
Were you one of the designers?
Have you ever considered updating the
website to make it a little more modern?
I could give you an offer code with
squarespace and uh,
they weren't on the design team,
so they aren't still designing right
now.
So I know they said no,
thank you.
The website is to remain as it was in
march 97.
Really promoting our sponsors.
I've wanted to throw that in.
I looked like they could use it if I
wAnted to reach the next level.
What are the main stePs I should take?
Predators destroying the power cable.
By the way,
I read that the next levels and actual
planet.
Is there an actual hell to like must've
far in the outer rim.
That's where a,
is that a reference?
I'm not getting cut off mannequins arms,
uh,
the next levels across universe.
There are no steps that can be taken in
this era.
So if you want to go now you're kind of
out of luck.
Um,
you're ranked number seven on watch
mojo's list of top 10.
What do you think of that?
I thought that was funny.
They still answering.
Uh,
I mean,
I figured that's kind of an honor,
right?
We don't think watch mojo means that
much load on shots at one time.
Yep.
Yeah.
WhaT is the biggest misconception you
believe people have when it comes to the
group at the members were weak minded,
gullible,
and brainwashed.
Just the opposite is true.
Uh,
I read that the group purchased alien
abduction insurance from a uk based
insurance provider prior to march.
Twenty.
Fourth is,
is this true?
This is like a rumor floating around and
it's on their wikipedia that they bought
alien abduction insurance.
Uh,
there's actually a company in,
in the best business ever to be in.
How much does it cost for alien?
And there's a.
Anyone listening right now,
if you want aliens,
parents email me,
I'll assure you.
There's a company in the uk and geico
has a report on it that they've sold
over 30,000
insurance policies that is the best.
They said that they looked into it but
didn't buy it.
The internet turned a humorous inquiry
by us into a weird insurance event that
never happened.
It was blown way out of proportion.
So they just goofed.
So this is,
uh,
I.
This is pretty,
in a short way.
I asked if lil uzi vert could help carry
the torch and spread the word if he's
open to learning with this new movement.
He mentioned or does he not have what it
takes?
They go,
lil uzi vert would have to make a
dramatic change in his grasp of what the
next level is really like.
It would fizzle so they don't trust him
to carry on the legacy at a concert
recently,
this freaked everyone out where he said,
you guys are basically old friend.
I know.
We feel like you're like one.
I feel like ian's going to show up
covered in a blanket with some nike's on
and a couple of weeks after,
I don't know if I'm going to stop
talking to suck then I know I'm saying
I'm concerned.
I've started to rethink some things.
I may need to get some insurance.
I got you,
but were you at a concert recently?
Uzi vert kind of freaked out his fans
because he said you,
uh,
you all have entered the rapture.
No one's flying up to heaven.
Obviously.
All of you are going to hell ride with
me.
You're already here.
So sorry you can't get out.
You're stuck.
It's over.
You heard the songs a million times.
You didn't even know.
So he's saying that his songs are like a
gateway to getting people to go to hell.
That's pretty bow thing to say to your
fans.
And that was just like what?
His fans got kind of freaked out by
expecting like the ground to like open
up from that minute.
I asked what did they think it is?
If you say lil uzi vert fast enough,
it sounds like lucifer,
lil uzi vert lucifer.
And uh,
I,
uh,
they said he does not know the ways of
the next level.
Everything he talkS about has nothing to
do with us.
He has to comply with copyright law and
what's with little uzi?
Is he really like?
He's just doing an act.
Okay.
Yeah.
I think for the it splitting,
this is a picture that's on,
on his facebook,
his official facebook is a advert
starting a luciferian space.
Colt and dragging his fans to hell is
kind of the question that looks pretty
serious.
That panic.
I don't know if that's official painting
on a.
Nicki minaj released a song this
morning.
One of the lyrics was like,
when I told uzi to go to hell,
I didn't mean it literally.
And uh,
that's,
that's today has representatives did not
respond to requests for comment.
I reached out to uzis,
uh,
people.
Yeah.
Is a little easier ever.
PlanninG on starting a space.
Colt uzi,
vert demon.
Should I be scared of ms.dot.
You're credible.
You're increase luck in they didn't
answer and I have no.
I have no idea why they wouldn't answer
us.
Disreputable hd pacas no to us.
Ian,
since insane on.
So the moral of the story really after
all this is beware of rappers offering
you applesauce.
You know,
it may be poisoned.
Sure.
Don't get sucked in.
Just don't eat applesauce.
Be safe.
Avoid applesauce all together because
what are you.
If you're over the age of a year.
Yeah.
A watch out for guys that looked like
this.
This is a photo taken from their
websites on the landing page,
how a member of the kingdom of heaven
might appear.
So if you see a guy dealt fast tracks
Who hop on like some adidas.
Yeah.
Everything about sneaker heads,
they're all very fashionable.
So if you see that guy walked around,
you know,
look out and get some abduction
insurance really cut.
And that's uh,
that's the end.
So that's what we learned.
Give me some applause.
That was another great presentation to
intern.
Tom,
before I
send you out,
tell me about your.
How was the reporting that I was talking
with the members of this infamous colt?
I mean,
did you feel a lord?
Cause they had some kind of a business
like charm.
I'll say,
did you feel like you wanted to hang out
with that?
Tell me,
did you learn anything?
Yeah,
I.
Well,
at first I was like,
oh god,
are these people gonna be weird and
freaky and try and find out what like
scientology will kind of comfort.
These guys have kind of been like,
we're good.
We got 900 years To chill out.
So they're not very urgent.
You're pretty relaxed.
Just don't mess with their copyrights.
Most definitely.
Well apparently they are not suing.
They're threatening to sue their
threatening and now he seems like he may
be changing the keys back in.
Oh wow.
So it's an interesting story.
ThAt's a shame.
All right,
thank you andrew.
Thank you.
That's
5:00
for you.
Destroy the child guys.
Thank you for watching.
Remember to head uP rePresent.com/huh?
Street for this sick ass two weeks only
available.
Grateful dead march.
Inspired march.
This was a rough ride.
I maybe will do the Alex Jones segment
later because I think it's good,
but I just can't do it now.
I feel so exhausted,
man.
Hope this was a washable episode.
Was a wild,
weird fricken twisted ride and now we
have to upload it tomorrow because it's
already like six.
Takes eiGht hours.
I mean,
it takes to eight.
Put it up too late.
We've got to upload it tomorrow.
Oh well.
So guys,
stay tuned because we have gotten a
slamming schedule.
Jacksepticeye bert kreischer,
tim decker,
adam carolla looking good for the hp
partner.
As long as we don't get banned from live
streaming on youtube,
everything's looking up for us and
remember,
we'll see you in the next level.
Thanks for mother.
Ship is in the sky and I'm about to hit
your ride.
That means kill myself.
All right guys,
catch you.
Next time tata.